بدات الغرب له يعني تجارب كثيره فيها في
دعم هذا الحركات
والغرب لا مشكله لديه في دعم هذه الحركات
طالما يحقق المصلحه
واحيلك ايضا الى سيادتك الى مقال كتبه
مصطفى حامد ابو الوليد المصري في خلال هذا
الشهر على موقعي الالكتروني الذي يصدر
وبغرابه من طهران هذا الموقع يصدر وهذا
الرجل هو مؤرخ تنظيم القاعده له اكثر من
عشرين كتابا في التاريخ لتنظيم القاعده
كتب مقالا مهما للغايه خلال هذا الشهر عن
حرب الموانئ وحرب البحار واستدل بما يحدث
في اوكرانيا وقال ان الهجوم على
احدى المركبات او احدى السفن
الروسيه وتفجيرها هذا مهم جدا سوف يدفع
الروس للافراج عن صواريخ بحريه الى الينا
يعني سوف يدفع وهذه الصواريخ سوف تصل
الينا ومن ثم نحن لابد علينا ان نط ور ما
يسمى بحروب الموانئ وحروب البحار واول شيء
واول ساحه يمكن ان نستفيد من خلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه هي الساحه اليمنيه
الصوماليه حيث هذه المنطقه منطقه بحريه
هامه يحدث لابد ان يحدث تبادل وتدريب هنا
ونقل الاس والتدريبات من الحوشي الى
الصومال والعكس من الصومال الحوثي هذا
الكلام ما اقوله معنى كلامه لكن بالنص
بالنص ما قاله مصطفى حامد يؤشر على كيفيه
المتابع حضرتك متخصص تعريف فلو بكلمتين عن
مصطفى حامد من هو مصطفى حامد بس عشان
يعرفوا الناس قيمه كلامها مصطفى حامد
مصطفى حامد هو كان بدا عمله كصحفي كان
مراسلا لقناه
الجزيره انتقل الى افغانستان كمراسل انضم
الى جماعه سياف لفتره ثم عاد الى مصر
ومصري من محافظه الاسكندريه
عام 2011 عاد الى مصر
ثم الى مستشار لسياف ثم عمل مستشارا
لاسامه بن لادن لفتره طويله ثم عمل كمؤرخ
لتنظيم القاعده وله اكثر من 20 كتاب
لتاريخ تنظيم نعم وهو موجود وهو موجود في
ايران موجود في ايران حاليا موجود في
طهران طيب هو شهر سيف العدل